bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors grande journée de
mobilisation nationale ce jeudi
cheminots enseignants personnels de
santé
de nombreux corps de métiers seront dans
les rues cet après midi quelle analyse
faites-vous de cette reprise de la
mobilisation syndicale
alors moi je jouerai cinq mots colère et
souffrance on va dire que c'est un seul
mot parce que la situation va pas le
plan castex ne répond points résistance
mais la question du sens et le troisième
mot c'est capital parce que ces
résistances contre la domination du
capital et on a besoin de créer un grand
mouvement contre la domination du
capital
quatrièmement contre la domination mais
pourquoi pour l'emploi et les services
publics
si haut le coeur de l'ensemble c'est les
travailleurs leur sécurisation qui sont
décisifs or on a fait l'argent pour le
capital pas pour l'hôpital et plus
largement il faut faire l'argent pour
les femmes et les hommes pour une autre
production et donc mon cinquième mots
après colère résistance capital emploi
service public c'est une autre logique
une autre logique il faut que l'argent
vienne appuyer les femmes et des hommes
leur sécurisation leur qualification au
lieu que ça vient d'appuyer le capital
le financier la prédation les
délocalisations l'investissement qui
vient accompagner les femmes et des
hommes pour une autre production via la
colère il ya la colère les gens sont
sidérés il pense que le gouvernement
fait ce qui peut c'est pas vrai c'est
pas vrai ils n'ont pas sécurisé les gens
ils disent qu'ils sécurisent mais en
réalité on a sept cent mille chômeurs de
plus de fin de cdd et à l'intérim et des
milliers de licenciements prévus
rien zéro pour l'hôpital epsilon
d'emplois alors qu'il en faut 100 milles
et qu'on nous parle d'une seconde vague
donc c'est terrible il faut s'y prendre
autrement et là c'est mon avis c'est un
coup d'arrêt qui est marqué pour les
désirs les syndicats appellent
finalement le gouvernant à sécuriser
l'emploi sécuriser les travailleurs et
non les entreprises est ce que selon
vous c'est ce qui est fait actuellement
alors moi je ne suis pas d'accord pour
dire laisser les entreprises au patronat
le gouvernement
sécurise pas les entreprises quand il
démolit les travailleurs c'est pas vrai
il nous prétend qu'il a fait la demande
et que maintenant faut faire l'offre
mais l'offre c'est les entreprises et
donc c'est les travailleurs leurs
compétences et des projets de production
donc c'est garder les gens voir avec eux
comment elle va évoluer comment on va
l'investir
regardez general electric on ferme la
turbine hydraulique c'est à dire celle
qui permet de faire l'électricité la
plus propre on ferme on licencie on
ferme les filages de maintenance du
nucléaire alors que la maintenance
nucléaire c'est décisif pour la sécurité
on ferme thales les cartes sim en
normandie on ferme le ferez ter et le
fret ferroviaire
le fret ferroviaire zéro emploi et on
ferme les choses donc ça ne va pas du
tout c'est de la folie c'est de l'argent
pour le capital et les profits pas pour
les entreprises il faut sécuriser
développer les salariés allaient vers
même un système de sécurité d'emploi ou
de formation inverser les logiques boli
baisser le coût du capital pour
développer les femmes les hommes
vous êtes même dans les médias mais bfm
ils vont licencier des dizaines et des
dizaines de gens comment on peut faire
sans les femmes les hommes et les femmes
et les hommes qui sont décisifs
aujourd'hui et on veut marcher sur la
tête
on reconnaît que les femmes et d'hommes
sont décisifs parce que le gouvernement
dit on sécurise
mais en réalité il démolit il démolit y
démoli pour quoi faire pour satisfaire
les profils capital pas les entreprises
alors on sait qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
conséquences économiques qui ont découlé
de la crise sanitaire est ce que les
revendications des syndicats sont
réalistes en tout cas avec la situation
économique actuelle
vous avez raison de poser la question il
ya des milliers de milliards qui sont
déversées sur les entreprises locales
sont réalistes parce que c'est une
utilisation de l'argent qui est posée
qu'est ce qui fait le le joint entre les
aspirations et une belle logique c'est
l'utilisation de l'argent
l'état dit kim et 100 milliards il a mis
déjà 300 millions avant et la banque
centrale européenne mais des milliers de
milliards des milliers de lumières
ça va faire 3 à 6 ans voire 900
milliards pour la france
à ce point là cc c'est trois fois plus
grand que le budget de la france donc il
ya danger
et on en met mais on le met pour
conforter le capital pour le développer
et et et pour démolir en quoi alors il
faut pas demander les contreparties à un
poison on va pas demander qu'on supprime
moins d'emploi par exemple le
gouvernement pour les jeunes vous
m'aviez interviewer juillet ils
proposent des cdd de 3 mois et donc on
met subventions et comme condition des
cdd de 3 mois maintenant on va pas
demander plus ou moins de précarité on
va pas demander plus ou moins de poison
il faut une autre logique sur cet avion
et c'est possible parce que bien sûr
nous sommes en difficulté mais les
difficultés commencent et avant le corps
humain
le corps n'a été révélateur les à
démultiplier et aujourd'hui on voit
qu'on peut mettre de l'argent mais il
faut une toute autre logique une toute
autre démocratie ça va pas du tout ils
font les choses à l'envers tout freins
serrés et donc effectivement les
revendications des salariés et moi je
serai avec eux parce que c'est aussi le
rôle des intellectuels dans la rue ils
ont raison mais pas que dans la rue dans
une résistance prix à pied moi je pense
qu'il faudrait dans tous les territoires
et j'appelle le gouvernement et tout le
monde a réuni des conférences permanente
permanente pour l'emploi la formation et
la transformation productive qui
s'intéressera à l'utilisation de
l'argent avec des engagements prises par
les entreprises et services publics
combien d'emplois ont créé comment on a
pu et quels investissements pour appuyer
ses emplois et non pas qu'elles
emploient en supprime dernière les
investissements fait avec boca merci
d'avoir été avec moi je rappelle que
vous êtes économiste et membre des
économistes atterrés inversis